[Musik]
erfreut was bedeutet ihnen jetzt dass
das kunstwerk am hauptbahnhof wundern
warum hoffen es passiert hoffentlich
platzt jetzt nicht trainiert und jetzt
nicht die stunde der wahrheit
sam keller steht kurz vor einem
höhepunkt seiner beruflichen karriere
schon immer zum würzen sohn zu größerem
heute ist keller eine der weltweit
einflussreichsten persönlichkeiten
hinter kunstszene
was ist das für eine der sich auf jedem
parkett geschickt bewegen kann und
welche träume lassen sich erfüllen wenn
man den schlüssel zur welt der reichen
und kreativen hat davon han gibt diese
reportage die fotos ihrer in basel
rischen reden
das kunstmuseum wird seit zehn jahren
von einem erfolgreichen direktor geführt
sam keller so fantastisch dass das
heimrecht
seit letztem jahr tag liefert stil aller
sozialer stolz dass hier eine
historische persönlichkeit die die
kunstszene sind sogar welt der mensch
aber natürlich hilft nur betreiben und
hilft zugang zu der künste die frau das
jupiter ist für ihn fast so etwas wie
ein zuhause das eine lieblingssorte
nimmt man dafür dass und landschaft lüge
sein elternhaus liegt nur gerade einen
steinwurf entfernt
der vater mich harnik mutter
krankenschwester die hälfte sind alles
andere als grundstoff vielen hat sie das
nie gehört also ein iphone zu klagen
kommt als hörer für gold die burgen und
kirchen alcoa legen die musiker und
birgit wird das glück das sind dann kam
ins schwitzen und museen kunst immer von
der möglichkeit das für mich entdecken
nach der matura veganer kunstgeschichte
und philosophie zu studieren
doch an der uni habe nicht das lernen
können was ihn interessierte
zeitgenössische kunst deshalb brauche
das studium ab wie finden wir es wieder
machen aber wir sind allen anderen
empfehlen
an der art basel fand der
studienabbrecher zuerst einen
aushilfsjob
schnell wurde man auf den ehrgeizigen
jungen mann aufmerksam
im jahr 2000 schaffte er es zum direktor
der kunstmesse er führte sie zu weltruhm
dank eines ablegers in miami
die art basel zieht die schönen und
reichen schwarm weise an hollywood
schauspieler brad pitt
designer karl lagerfeld oder auch
topmodel naomi campbell
2008 hob ihn ernst beyeler als leiter in
sein museum keller wohnt nicht nur in
basel
hier lägen auch seine wurzeln der wahl
staunt wie bodenständig sich der
weltweit erfolgreiche kunstmanager gibt
keller bewegt sich wie ein fisch im
wasser durchs leben in der kunstwelt
fühlt er sich genauso zu hause wie im
fußballstadion
er besitzt eine jahreskarte im basler
joggeli
also hauskauf und die sieben tagen der
woche in jeder folge
emotionen im stadion sind toll
[Applaus]
wir gehen können focus hat ja mit seiner
bürger sind sie dann verkaufte porsche
muss jetzt weg und punkte nach
mit
bucher gruppe privater sehr fair geführt
wollen fußballer wollten
bis zum heutigen tag blieben basel trotz
job angeboten aus der ganzen welt
der 52 jahre auf dessen keller ist
verheiratet und vater eines erwachsenen
sohnes filmaufnahmen bei sich daheim
sind tabu also ich hab mir vor aber
sehen um mehr als sie zu hause glänzt
durch abwesenheit weil der preis nicht
ein höherer preis dafür dass ich
plötzlich mein vorwurf machen
tob ich will wichtige sie als familie
foto fro doch natürlich natürlich und
radikal war ja aber wir haben eben nicht
mehr denn je gut verhalten ist die fahrt
so ist drehe mal am tag der hai xiii zu
masse und trotzdem haben nicht immer
gekürzt verhalten ist gar also nur fotos
wo man miteinander verbringt der
luftschleuse wie gut erhalten ist das
eine thema richtiges argument innere
bezirk was mit ihr glücklicher tag über
längere distanz zu steil und dass wir
jetzt schon klima klimakrise georg huber
keller sagt man er habe viele tausend
freunde das morgen betrieben seien gut
vernetzt ist er allemal
arbeit und privatleben trennt der
museumsdirektor kaum voneinander ruf
erschaffen hat und man gelebt wo freunde
sind mit einer schafft man spielt und
eigentlich muss mit toilette sondern in
berlin um uhren hopfer er ist eine
person mit extrem viel energie
manchmal ist es schwierig mit seiner
energie mithalten zu können
eigentlich vor dem kunstwerk partie
zieht gar nicht verdient dass ich mir
jedes problem und sie haben kann ich
jetzt jedes meiner seite
das heißt wir da wird der abend wird
lang die nachtruhe kurz morgen reist er
in einer schön nach brasilien
für rio de janeiros touristischen reize
hat er kaum ein auge übrig in seiner
welt dreht sich alles um kunst
[Musik]
ich finde es lustig kannst du kannst
entwürfen york das kolleg auf dem
programm steht beim besuch im atelier
eines der bedeutendsten zeitgenössischen
künstler lateinamerikas und das ist der
erste netto in den größten museen der
welt sind seine werke zu sehen
new york london und paris 2006 ernannte
frankreich dem brasilianer sogar zum
richter künftig 20 euro
was macht ihnen denn so gastfreundlich
hus erstmal ist der unterbau
persönlichkeit charismatisch
blitzgescheit politischen poeten und
dennoch groß die herzlichkeit und
dennoch in der richterschaft skulptur
gefunden hat oder mit mit materialien
und
wo man einen großen handwerklichen kennt
seinen werken liegt die
auseinandersetzung mit spiritualität
zugrunde urwald indianer sind seine
vorbilder
ich mache gerade eine diät die ich bei
den indianern kennengelernt habe ich war
bei den japanern aber indianern dort
machen wir spirituelle sitzungen um mich
besser fokussieren zu können
es ist gut damit zu machen
es ist teil meiner arbeit hat jetzt das
jetzt nicht so und ich glaube es halt
ich seit sie ist aber einige beobachter
trinke bier raucher rauchen sagt große
diskrepanz klares und naja ich hab drei
diesel abgaben und chris kaman und
bringt rauch kam
und solange man sich noch einigermaßen
guten viel viel zu nass gewesen dann
bereitet sich der künstler innerlich auf
das interview vor das ist die zentrale
aussage ihre kunst das versuche ich seit
30 jahren heraus zu finden
ich denke die mir stehen in einem
ausbalancierten verhältnis zueinander
wir sind mit allem verbunden was uns
umgibt
[Musik]
im unteren stock formell das atelier
befindet sich die produktions werkstatt
acht angestellte setzen hier die
visionen des künstlers
die werke werden aus natur gefärbt der
baum wurde gefochten
das heißt sie haben die idee des
kunstwerkes und andere setzen sie ja
mein hens viele hände
dank kellers initiative ich diesen
sommer in zürich eine installation des
künstlers zu sehen
sie kostet 2,7 millionen franken
nach abzug aller spesen blieben ihm nur
gerade 50 tausend franken als realen
verdienst sagt netto und wie viel
bezahlt das einen angestellten pro tag
150 reales als er rund 40 franken
dass ich nicht viel nein nicht viel
das macht ihnen nichts aus doch sie
sollten mehr erhalten das heißt sie noch
in das große geld nicht so sehr die
herstellung kostet eine menge
vielleicht sollte ich mit ihnen mehr
teilen ich weiß es nicht ich denke ich
sollte werden sie ja das werde ich 40
franken tageslohn mögen für unsere
verhältnisse nicht viel sein aber in
brasilien entspricht das dem doppelten
des mindestlohns
am kunstwerk für zürich arbeitete das
team drei jahre lang die kunstschule
packelei schmidt mio fototermin auf der
terrasse mit einer großen kultur zeitung
der geplante artikel über den schweizer
museumsdirektor hat franchise reynolds
eingefädelt sie ist die ex frau des
besitzers von globo dem größten
medienkonzern lateinamerikas das ist
arbeit aber was toll ist aber dass sie
noch da unser wunderschönes die nato mit
interessanten job wo sie haben ja wenn
ja wer nächster netto fährt an diesem
tag dorthin wo die quelle seines
schaffens liegt im wald bei den
indianern in den bergen oberhalb just
richter den schamanen alvaro tucano der
inde hahn richter politische anführer
der eiffelturm lateinamerikas mit dabei
ist auch nicht als freund raphael an
trio gemeinsam führen sie ein
harmonisches ritual durch
hatte das ist tabak und asche eines
baumes tabak
bald medizin
die mischung geht nicht in die lunge
sondern direkt ins hirn es halt vieles
um die schamanen wenden es an
in unserer großen probleme zu lösen
[Musik]
meine rolle als heiler ist es die leute
wieder mit der natur zu verbinden
[Musik]
in der region wohnt der kunstmanager in
der villa von franchise reynolds mit der
kunst mit zähnen ist keller seit jahren
befreundet
das leben im luxus am morgen aufzuwachen
und zu fragen und um gab es davor
wunderbar bäume und sie zu fuß und mit
guter fruchtsaft vermögenswerten
was sollten schon so müssen die eltern
taxis ist was absolut morgens ist
franchise reynolds besitzt
luxuswohnungen in aller welt in ihren
domizilen hängen werke von namhaften
künstlern
[Musik]
was steht da kunst ist nicht nur für die
reichen
der direkte des populärsten museums der
schweiz hat die größte kunstmesse der
welt verändert das ist fantastisch den
rest über sich dann noch großzügig
eine weltweit einflussreiche
persönlichkeit ein vorbild ein
beschützer und man hat mit ihm viel spaß
und er ist ein großartiger teamplayer
für den teamplayer wartet noch viel
arbeit in rio dabei geht es ums geschäft
hinter der kunst viel geld aber davon
verlieren wie eine menge beginnen steuer
wenn du die richtige lösung findet musst
du dir keine sorgen machen du schickst
ihm das geld hatte braucht einen vertrag
in langen nächten geht es um
sponsorensuche für netto 2 7 millionen
projekt in zürich es braucht viele leute
die ein herz für kunst haben schließlich
eröffne keller noch einen abend an dem
der künstler vor publikum spricht ihn
braucht man nicht vorzustellen denn er
ist in brasilien anhält nur mich kennt
hier niemand
schon bald wird der nächste netto in die
schweiz reisen um sein jüngstes werk zu
präsentieren
[Musik]
freitagabend 29 juni vernissage der
installation gejammert rey im zürcher
hauptbahnhof nettes begehbares werk ist
riesig 20 meter hoch 1,5 tonnen schwer
und hergestellt das über 10.000 meter
baumwollstoff wie sie in der juli finden
verschiedene veranstaltungen im innern
des krisenstabs im keller kommt ins
schwärmen sind viele jahren und
kunstprojekte das schaf von ganz kleinen
das heißt so groß aber das ist größte
vollen insofern dicksten voll und das
ist jetzt wirklich irgendwo lang und
toni lang und freue mich sehr mit dem
minister und
das daher vereinbart war dass ich ja
bisweilen groß kind erzählen davon
naja
mit einem indianischen segen übergibt
ernesto neto sein werk dem publikum
und seinem keller gut möglich dass er
bereits wieder träumt von einer neuen
projekt
[Applaus]